[Music]
this is i think without doubt one of the
most spectacular migrations that you can
witness in north america if not the most
spectacular
there's just something really uplifting
and inspiring about them and and people
all over the world have have felt that
way
they're kind of impossible to resist
when the cranes arrive it's the first
time the spring's coming and then soon
after
the baby cats will be coming and hitting
the ground and the grass greens up it's
the start of the best time of year for
me
cranes have been in the in the world for
tens of millions of years and they've
been doing this migration for at least
10 000 years
[Music]
from what we know each individual crane
will spend about three to four weeks
here and they're doing a behavior that's
common with many other water birds
called staging they're kind of fattening
up for the rest of their journey and
then they're also
kind of meeting up with their friends
with their mates with family
they start doing certain social
behaviors here for the first time
[Music]
they get up and there there's a gigantic
lift off off the river and it is
actually deafening
so then they go out and they go to their
feeding areas in the cornfields
they're usually they're gone before we
put a seed in the ground so
we really co-exist pretty well
and for the cranes it's a breakfast
buffet all day all day all you can eat
buffet
the cranes have adapted to where is the
grain is very important to their diet
now we're probably really only leaving
about 250 pounds of corn that the
combine isn't getting and then the cows
are cleaning up part of that but the
cranes are thriving on that little
amount that we're we're leaving
they're some of the world's most
successful birds in terms of how long
they've been around on this planet and i
think eating they're eating corn even
though it's only been around for a
hundred years which is a tiny
portion of their evolution it's another
measure of their resilience and their
opportunism they're taking advantage of
a of a new food source
today in the platte river valley about
95 percent of their caloric intake is
from corn
it provides them
calories but it does not provide them
nutrients or protein and and some
essential minerals
they get that from these wet meadows
so even though santol cranes are doing
well they of course face threats just
like every other species the the number
one threat region-wide for them is the
loss of wetland habitat and loss of
habitat in general
we really need these meadows and that
we're to a point where we have to
preserve the last few percent that
remain along the big bend of the flat
and elsewhere
so we are working to restore these
prairies and also with multiple
objectives in mind to improve habitat
for cranes but also these other
grassland and wetland birds
[Music]
with the cranes they can't really shift
away from this river they really need
this river system and these birds are
adapted to water and they need that and
water obviously is affected by climate
the jury is kind of out on how climate
change will affect sand hills but we
know that their migration has advanced
they're arriving about 30 days earlier
than they did 20 years ago that's a very
rapid shift
they can deal with all sorts of changes
but they need water and they need
wetlands at the end of the day
i think they're resilient but i think
that it's not really about them it's
about this whole great plains
water bird ecosystem that is on the
verge of something very dangerous if we
don't really put our foot down and stop
it
so just because the cranes are abundant
it doesn't mean they're not fragile
they were over hunted and they lost a
lot of habitat going into the 1930s
and the u.s actually legislated to
protect them and other native birds
santo cranes can be hunted they in fact
are hunted in almost all states except
nebraska where we are now
but it's always under strict conditions
so i think the the success of these
birds is a combination of their own
natural resilience and also the fact
that humans have acted to to help them
to protect them
they're a symbol of hope because of
their own success on their own terms and
they also symbolize what humans can
achieve when we work together their
success is our success
[Music]
[Music]
you